We Begin this hour with a rare look into
an issue most of us may not know about
what it's like to be one of the millions
of kids in America who are translators
for their parents in the new movie
translators Emmy Award winning filmmaker
Rudy Valdez introduces us to three
Florida families the kids learn English
through school and end up acting as
translators for their families who
struggle to find time and resources to
learn the language sixteen-year-old
Virginia came to the U.S with her family
five years ago to escape violence in
Venezuela take a look don't give up
legendo
um
I know some of my friends that
they just don't want to help their
parents with translation they're like oh
she can figure out on her own she can
use translate let them solve that on
their own and I am not like that
I would not be painting I would not be
in all of these clubs that I like right
now
I have so much to thank them for they
left everything and I know they just
changed all of that because of us
Rudy Valdez joins us now it is such a
beautiful film and that sound bite that
we just played really really struck me
because you might think that for many
children having to translate for their
parents while dealing with schoolwork
and all the other parts of being a child
could be a burden but but all of the the
kids you interviewed said that they were
grateful for what their parents
sacrificed to bring them to this country
they were happy to help them in this way
yeah it was that was one of the most
fascinating things learning uh and
filming with these kids and families was
that it yeah it comes across as it could
be something that is a burden or super
stressful and it can be at times but
there's a real bonding that happens with
the kids and the families as they as
they navigate the world sort of together
in this in this I don't want to say
alternate way but this sort of nuanced
way of using language as access to to
more things so you sometimes hear uh
people say oh why don't you just learn
English already you know if you want to
live in this country you got to speak
the language in this country and I think
what they forget is like going back to
every wave of immigration that's ever
come to America who doesn't speak
English they the the first generation
rarely becomes fluent it's the kids that
become fluent why was it important for
you to address though head-on the sort
of question of why don't you learn
English already I mean for that same
reason because even while filming this
we ran into people asking me when they
say oh what are you filming and I'd say
oh and I'd give them sort of the gist of
what we're doing this like I know the
parents just don't learn English and I'm
like okay here's why and I have to go
into this Spiel of you know people are
coming to this country uh legally first
of all because that was the sort of the
first sort of hint of of some
politicizing of it and I was like
they're here and you know they don't
know the language they're not going to
be able to even though this person has a
degree as a teacher from their home
country they're not going to come here
and be able to be a teacher so they're
taking the job that they can right to be
able to support their family and they're
working 12 14 hours a day then they're
going to go home and study English for
two to three hours a night and they're
going and also it's just difficult for
an adult in general in general like
learn to use like the new remote control
like right let alone having a full play
yeah it's my first language I can bear I
barely have a grasp on it yeah
you're not the only one um there's a
moment in this film where a teenager is
translating a medical questions and
answers for his parents
um what type of for her parents excuse
me what type of impact does that have on
a kid yeah I mean
you can see in the film she's very she's
stressed out about that because she says
to her mom if I get one word wrong like
the implications of that could who knows
she's very nervous about that and you
know I think at the at the core of all
this what we're learning is language is
access language is trust language in in
there again it creates that bonding
mechanism between the the the family
members because the mother says to her
you're going to do it you can do it
trust yourself and and you know these
are lessons and the mom has complete
faith in her daughter and even if the
daughter doesn't have faith in herself
she's learning to navigate that and and
be resilient through all of that so it's
fascinating to watch it truly is seeing
the children take on this almost almost
co-parenting role by translating right
and being part of the conversation with
the doctor is amazing it brings the
family together but then you also see
the kids then at least one of them
didn't want to move away after high
school because she wanted to stay close
to her parents and you can only think
that that was because she knew that her
parents needed her yeah yeah and I think
you know we I talked to Virginia about
that all the time and you know she's
opening up to the fact that yes she she
wants to go on and live her life but she
always has this thing that she's very
appreciative of what her family has done
because what we're thinking of right now
is all the sacrifices that she is making
to help her family but
what we don't always understand is all
the sacrifices that our family made to
bring her here and give her these
opportunities and she's trying to
reciprocate that by giving it back to
her and she she also understands she has
a younger brother and she's like he will
then take on that role when he's old
enough so she just wants to make sure
that that sort of Gap is bridged until
she moves on so it's it's it's such a
beautiful experience watching uh the way
they're navigating everything you have
to grow up fast 11 million Children
Service translators for their families
huge and Latino communities but also you
know other languages and other
communities as well rude thank you so
much thank you translators is available
now at translatorsfilm.com